la oms junto con gaby que es la alianza
para las vacunas y países que apoyaron
esta visión el mecanismo kóvacs con esto
querían asegurar que por lo menos el 20%
de la población tuviera acceso a vacunas
de calidad sin embargo los países con
más recursos iniciaron el negociaciones
directas con las farmacéuticas y
compraron la mayor cantidad de dosis en
el mercado que hay actualmente esto pone
en desventaja a los países pobres que no
han tenido el mismo acceso a las vacunas
y que muchos países ni siquiera han
iniciado a calcular esto es por algunos
problemas uno la capacidad de las
farmacéuticas en producir las vacunas
otro es las agencias reguladoras y que
hayan autorizado la vacuna otro las
efectividades de la vacuna y sabemos que
hay vacunas que son desde el 50 por
ciento desde el 90 95 por ciento de la
actividad
dependiendo
el tipo de vacuna de la que se trate sin
embargo todo esto no son simplemente
cuestiones de un país es cuestiones está
afectando a todo el mundo entonces no
todo el mundo puede tener acceso al
mismo tiempo no todo el mundo puede
tener la vacuna no pudo todo el mundo
puede tener lo que estamos buscando sin
embargo
aquí viene la parte de equidad que los
países pobres puedan tener acceso a la
vacuna que es una cuestión de equidad
global